Let's look at the solution to the first part of our quiz. The question was,
what is in these registers and in these RAT entries? And to answer that,
we need to consider all of the things that can happen in this cycle.
One of the things that happens is we will try to issue this instruction.
That might update the RAT. Another thing that we need to consider is that this
instruction will broadcast its result, and that might also update the RAT and
write to a register. We can do this in either order, but
we have to figure out if they update the same thing, what happens. So let's see.
Issuing this instruction results in looking at the RAT entries for
F0 and F1. And then, writing to the entry for
F1 the number of the reservation station where we put this instruction.
Because there is an available reservation station,
this instruction will issue there. So the entry for
F1 will be changed to point to a reservation station 2. The registers
are not updated when we issue an instruction. So they stay the same for
now. The broadcast of the result might update both the RAT and the registers.
Let's first see what happens to the RAT. We're broadcasting that RS0 is now 4.4.
And that will be written to registers. So from now on, we will not be using RS0
as the name for this value. That means that this RAT entry will
from now on be pointing to the actual register, where we write this result, and
that register is F0. So this RAT entry from now on points to the registry file.
Because the RAT entry was pointing to RS0 and RS0 is broadcasting,
that means that the register file will get value 4.4 for that register.
So the register here will change and finally this register here,
nobody wrote to it in this cycle, so it stays the same as it was.